welcome back to the Rich Eisen show you
know when I host the combine for NFL
Network there's so much to try and take
in one of my favorite stories that I
heard that I'm ready
eager to get confirmed right here that
my next guest
Tristan wharfs who was a two-time state
champion in the shot put and discus for
his track and field practice in his home
town population of about 4,000 plus
Mount Vernon Iowa would throw his discus
so far in the track and field practice
that it would wind up past a fence and
land in a tennis court on the other side
of the fence and that he had to alter
his practice schedule for the safety of
the people who played tennis on that
Court Tristan works here on the
Richardson show how are you Tristan is
that a true story that I just told yet
so somebody's playing tennis and out
here comes a discus that you threw so
far that nobody thought it could laugh
he couldn't go that far is that
literally what was happening yeah pretty
much the girls tennis team was out there
practicing and uh we would be practice
at the same time and you know I just
my first one what happened my junior
year and they're out there and it went
flying by this girl's head and they're
like yeah we can't we can't do this
anymore so but you were at least you
were accommodating like you'll change
your schedule they didn't have to change
their schedule you'll just change your
schedule to to warm up their whole team
me throw on so ooh easier for me to find
a whole new time well did it leave a
mark in the hard court like a divot yeah
well it wouldn't even if it but you
could see it like it's like scrape like
the medal remember the discus would
scrape that hard court when did you
realize that you could do things like
that for the first time Tristan oh I
think he was just you know over the
course of you know growing up like I
just I
just try something or see something I'd
want to try and then you know if I
couldn't get it I'd keep trying until I
got it and if you know I got the first
time then then I got it so it was really
like you know one one specific time wire
to start to do all these things they're
just kind of you know over the course of
growing up you know being you know
outside all the time climbing on stuff
you don't want to see if I can you know
jump up and touch something or you know
just stuff like that so I think you know
just it just always been happen as a kid
and when did you say okay let's give
this football thing a try Wendy who was
the first one to say let's do this you
know I've been playing flight football
for years early as I could remember and
I had to go to Cedar Rapids ten 15
minutes away from Mount Vernon to to
play tackle football in fourth grade
because Malvern didn't have it that
early so fourth grade was the first time
I played tackle football fourth grade
tackle football yeah but you said yep
okay were you taking people down Tristan
I mean where do you have a head on a
swivel in the fourth grade that's when
you're ten years old that must have been
significant a lot of guys you know rocky
Lombardi is okay who's that I use the
Michigan State Court means the Michigan
State quarterback right now yeah yeah
I'm a I'm a Wolverine Tristan Tristan
RIT Tristan I'm a Wolverine you know I
don't I don't I don't pay attention to
that school and green oh my gosh I mean
you know the whole time so did you were
you were you playing other fourth
graders or did you did you step up and
in grade when you're playing that okay
good and now I'm watching you on the
screen right here of you putting up over
500 pounds what in the world is that
like I mean when you what I honestly
been trying to put myself in your shoes
with that feat of strength that you're
able to pull off that we're seeing on
the screen Hawkeye football yeah that
was a pretty that was a pretty surreal
moment you know we had our weight room
records down on the wall in the hallway
we walk by everyday you know go to the
way you're going to practice
and it was always on my mind you know
like I remember I got there and you know
a lot of people were telling me that is
like Oh that'll never be broken and it
just gave me something to shoot for you
know and then that day was pretty was
pretty special you know I walked into
the new facility and guys were asking me
you know what I was gonna have on the
bar you know how much how much I was
going to do and I really didn't I really
had no idea and I remember getting in
the womb coach Doyle grabbed my my left
card from any hero down for 50 on it so
it's pretty much you know just had to
had to strap up and and and get after it
and you're just I'm just watching you
scream right now and your your your
teammates behind you just going totally
nuts and that must have been a heck of a
feeling Tristan works here on the Rich
Eisen show what you what has your
process of been like no pro day and
obviously there will be no face-to-face
visits how often are you
I guess zooming teleconferencing with
teams right now Tristan yes three or
four phone calls and I had my first zoom
one earlier this week then I got a lot
more sketch you know a lot more schedule
than in the coming in the coming weeks
but yeah it's definitely definitely
different very very weird times you know
not having the pro day and and not being
around you know my teammates training
with them and everything you know just
trying to stay as close to you know in a
routine as I can
there's a little gym and an Iowa City
where you know they let me come in and
train so that's been that's been real
nice you know just trying to try and
keep up you know the routine like we had
a you know when we're training with
coach Doyle he sent us he sent us lift
cards like just through text so we could
you know keep doing what we were doing
which yeah it's been different which
teams have you spoken to Tristan the
Buccaneers I had Buccaneers I'd the zoom
call with I had a FaceTime with the
Patriots a call with the Ravens a call
with the with the charges and dolphins
and then I got the Browns the Cardinals
and the Falcons coming up next week and
there's one more that's in my phone like
I can't remember top of my head well you
man in demand Tristan worse I did did
ferret did Kirk Ferentz fix you up with
the Patriots one I know of him and
Belichick go way way back yeah they've
known each other for court for quite a
while okay
and so was was Bill on the call was
Bella check on the cell phone okay and
was the same thing what about the Bucs
was Ariens I know he wasn't on there I
had 200 line guys and then I think their
OC well I mean well left which is the
man it's I mean what would that be like
if you protect Tom Brady obviously I
know you want to get in a certain spot
it doesn't matter who takes you you'll
give him a hundred percent but what
would that mean for you to protect Tom
Brady as a freshman in the NFL yeah that
would be pretty that would be pretty
crazy honestly you know because Tom
Brady you know he's been in the league
for almost as you know since I've been
born you know he came in with 2000 I was
born in 99 so that's I think that's
pretty crazy just thinking about that
but you know getting the block for him
would be you know would be pretty
amazing yeah I imagine it I imagine it
would be and you know when you are
envisioning your career Tristan what
what was because there's a ton of
competition at your spot what would you
say about what a team would get with you
who would a team get interest in worse
should they choose you as the first
Lyman's second lineman or just in the
first round who would they get yeah I
think I'm gonna come to work every day
you know ready to go I think you know
that plays you know plays a role from
coming from universal you know where
he'll do a higher standard I think you
know coach Doyle coach parents they're
they're no-nonsense type of guys so yeah
I was gonna come in and handle my
business and and do my best to get the
job done okay what's it like to wave to
the Children's Hospital and see the kids
wave back Tristan oh yeah what is that
donating getting to be a part of that is
extremely special
my freshman year area my freshman year
we had a or my sophomore year sorry one
of our one of the other alignment he had
twin daughters that were born during the
season then they were up there for one
of the games they're a little bit
premature but just getting to have
somebody that you know up there waving
to them it's pretty special and and I
love I love going over there and visit
visit visiting with the kids because you
know sometimes it's football players
well we're gonna have that attitude
where it's like oh we have to go do this
we have to go to that you don't have to
go out to practice or something and then
you go up there and and visit with those
kids and and you know just it just puts
a smile on their face and you know their
parents will say oh I haven't heard them
laugh and how long you know I seen a
smile and us just coming over and
spending a little bit of time with them
you know like we can get that out of
them you know kind of it totally changes
how you feel like we're we're able to
you know go out to practice and then put
in play the sport we love well these
kids are going you know up they're going
through things we can't even imagine
so I love I love you to them well you
know Tristan it is my it's it's my
favorite book the college football is
just amazing for so many reasons and
tradition is one of them it's my
favorite tradition in any college at any
spot that the the Children's Hospital
overlooks the stadium and everybody
stops and waves at the kids in the
window I mean I get I'm like I got three
kids 11 9 and 6 you know the run that I
I'd do it at the combine every year is
for st. Jude Children's Research
Hospital it's something so near and dear
like I'm getting emotional just talking
about it Tristan yeah yeah it's pretty
special you know I did the I was raising
money you know off my vertical jump to
get to the Children's Hospital at the
combine and that way you know I had so
much support in that you know the state
of Iowa and so many other people you
know are my goal was 33 inches then I
went 36 and a half and so like hopefully
I make everybody's money money worth it
you sure did man I mean that woman would
not know
came in front of us in the booth at NFL
Network we did look to see if there was
a misprint I'm not lying I mean somebody
your size is not supposed to jump that
high and then obviously running for
eight five at the combine not that was
something else so where do you think
you're gonna be spending draft night
right now which what is that plan right
now for you Tristan yeah probably just
probably just to get old Mount Vernon
with all my family okay and four
thousand of your or socially distant
friends in that town and that small town
yep okay so I'm glad to know that you're
well and and the girls tennis team is it
still all well correct that there's
survived your track and field process I
love that stories one of my favorite
stories and I look forward to seeing
where you wind up in the NFL and we'll
let's stay in touch as you go about your
career Tristan thanks for the call
you got it thank you for being here
thank you so much you bet my pleasure
a Tristan worth seventy four on Twitter
Tristan underscore worth seventy four
and Instagram one of the good ones